I guess my personal philosophy
almost always has to do with,
with,
in the most important way with the need
that I feel everyone has for an artistic
element in their lives and it doesn't
matter what their profession or their
that um,
I think that I heard once that everyone,
everyone in the world has written a
poem.
I don't know whether that's true,
but it should be true.
It must,
something like,
it must be true because I don't think
anyone lacks what we would call an
artistic impulse and what I feel more
than sort of political causes that I
might be interested in.
I think the,
the cause that I would embrace is the
idea that people might be encouraged to
experience even for a few moments in a
day.
The idea that,
uh,
that the imagination is ruling their,
their life for a moment.
Um,
and um,
that would be my prime cause in spite of
the fact that,
you know,
I have occasionally I have written
pieces with very frankly political
subjects and I've spent moments in my
life,
you know,
19,
64.
I went with all of the freedom summer
folks to Mississippi and with a group
from,
from here,
and we,
we definitely experienced an amazing
moment in the politics of this country,
but when I've addressed things like that
in my music,
it's been much more because it's part of
a whole emotional complex for myself
then that I want to convert we're or
influence opinion because unfortunately
the audience for such a piece usually
agrees
and I think,
you know,
if one were really to be serious about
the prison,
about moving people through the arts
politically,
you'd have to almost find a,
select your way into an audience that
doesn't like what you're saying,
what you're saying.
And very seldom of course,
do we ever do that?
It does.
It's probably the hardest thing for me
to articulate because most of my life as
a performer deals with forms of
religious music.
Um,
and I certainly feel that when I conduct
a Bach Cantata that I am a absolutely
engaged by,
not in an abstract way at all by the
issues and by the stories and the
experience.
Um,
but I can't,
I can't find a formal structure for
that.
And um,
when I write a religious text,
I would have to say that I am as gripped
by the ancient and the sound of the
words and the feeling that they are
carrying significance,
a almost that has been a sort of
gradually attached to them.
I'm over centuries.
Um,
I would like to feel that,
that all of the assertions were things I
can assert and that's not really how I
feel.
But the King James Bible,
I've come back to so often for texts and
it,
it was really translated at a moment
where the English language,
he had an extraordinary rhythmic and
verbal variety.
It's Shakespeare's era and I find
sometimes the passage,
this passage that attracts me has
unusual words or rhythms that I just
find absolutely irresistible.
Um,
in addition to,
of course it's,
it's accumulated significance,
but it's as much just a,
a deep affection for a text,
a love for a text as it is the whole
world of doctrine from which it merges.
And of course,
like a lot of people who are dealing
with church music.
And actually work as a church musician
some of the time,
it's terribly unsettling to have to
contemplate how much of the conflict in
the world to this day is generated by
religious groups,
by people who are fired up about the
doctrine.
And it's difficult for someone like
myself to embrace the institutional
issues having from a semi historian's
point of view,
a pretty firm idea that they often lead
to people fighting each other about it.
The hardest things,
you know,
compassion and forgiveness and a
tolerance,
which is also a really a hard one
because,
you know,
some of those,
some of the major issues in this
country,
you know,
race.
And,
um,
I'd have to even say a kind of
intellectual tolerance.
I'm very bothered that,
um,
many groups in this country are
dismissive of other groups because they
feel they're not as cultured,
not as educated.
I think we have a
very tremendous attraction to
intolerance almost bred into the early
life of this country.
And,
um,
so yeah,
I would consider those,
my
major virtues.
And also it's,
you know,
it's so hard
to apologize for things and I'm always
impressed by people who,
uh,
when they've done something really
wrong,
don't do the standard thing,
which is to make it worse and
ostracized,
but actually go the whole way and try to
reengage the situation.
Um,
and in our profession,
our music profession,
there are constant tests of those,
uh,
of those issues.